the goal for this video series is to
create a basic but good-looking data
science blog for free with minimal
effort this is what the final product
looks like and it was surprisingly easy
to build and didn't even require much
coding from me
in this video i'll show you how to get
your site up and running but in future
videos we'll cover how to add data
science content and how to further
customize your site to really make it
your own but before we get started
you'll need three things
first a github account which you can
create for free second you need to
install jekyll on your computer along
with its dependencies and i'll put a
link to this documentation in the
description
and third you need an ide or some kind
of text editor but here i'm going to be
using visual studio code since it really
integrates well with github
so you may be wondering why github pages
and why jekyll well github pages is
great because it can host your jekyll
site for free
github has great collaboration tools and
version control jekyll is a static site
generator that can turn your markdown
files and layouts
into a full html site so what's really
nice here is that we don't need to make
a new html page for each post because we
have layouts we just need to make
markdown files which are a lot easier so
let's get started
so the first step is going to be finding
a website template now you can build a
site from scratch with jekyll but there
are thousands of templates online that
have a lot of the boilerplate code
already set up for us so we don't need
to do a whole lot here are a couple
links i'll add in the description of
places that you can browse for jekyll
theme once you find one you like goes to
the github repo
so the theme i'll be using is called
clean blog jekyll and we'll go ahead and
take a look at the live preview
we've got our main home page which shows
us some of our most recent posts
we've got an about page our post page
which shows us all of our posts that we
can click through
and again these posts can be generated
for markdown files and don't necessarily
need a lot of code to be written for
them and last we have our contact page
but we're going to go back to our github
repo
and go to the top and we're going to
click fork
but essentially forking the repo creates
a copy of the website's repository and
it adds it to our own account
that way we can make our own changes on
our own website and we also need to
rename the repository so we'll go to
settings over here and for repository
name this is pretty important it needs
to be your username.github.io
so my username for github is datasliceyt
so i'm going to make my repository name
datasliceyt.github.io and it's important
you set it up this way so github knows
that this repository
is a github website and we'll click
rename so now we're going to locally
clone the website all these files right
now are in github but we want to get
them onto our computer that way we can
modify them
normally if you scroll down you'll see
installation and setup or something
similar in the readme of the repository
and generally you'll be fine following
those steps if i scroll down a bit
it specifically has steps for using core
files starting with cloning the
repository so this is what i'm going to
follow so in order to clone the
repository i'll go back up to the top
i'll click this little green button
and i'll copy this link now i'm going to
open up visual studio code
and click on the source control button
and then clone repository and i'll paste
that link that i just copied hit enter
and i'm just going to select a repo
location for it to copy the files to
then i'll go ahead and open my
repository
and you can see in visual studio code on
the left all the files here
are also the files that are in my github
repo so i've locally cloned it to my
computer and now i can start modifying
the files
and if we go back to the steps it says
we need to update our config.yml file
and once we've done that we can go ahead
and build our site to run locally
but before i modify my config yaml file
i just want to give you a brief overview
of the jekyll site structure because in
general they'll be roughly the same
so this config.yaml file stores our site
configuration data
now in general when you have a jekyll
site and you make modifications
they'll appear live on your site just
from refreshing the page but any changes
you make to your config.yml file you'll
need to actually stop your server
and then restart it to see those changes
and i'll show you what i mean in a
second the includes folder
usually contains snippets of html code
like your header or navigation bar
so we define the html code here and we
later embed them onto our pages
next is the layouts folder these are
templates or layouts for our different
pages
the idea is we could have one blog post
layout for our blog post but if we make
minor changes like changing the format
of the date under the title we'd only
need to do it on the layout page and
then all of those changes would be
propagated to
all of our blog posts the post folder
contains all of your blog posts and both
html files and markdown files are
supported here
the sas folder generally has where you'd
create sas files
that turn into the main css file for
your website you'll also notice that
there's some css files or scss files
under assets and you may have some other
folders like bin image and post that are
specific to your jekyll templates
repository and i'd recommend just taking
a quick look at them
just to see what kind of files are in
there and then in the parent folder
again you'll have the config file
you may also have some other html files
that are actually the main pages on your
website like about.html contact and
index
along with some other files specifically
there for
jekyll for your website to be able to
compile like the gem file
and the jekyll theme cleanblog.gemspec
file so just like the readme in our repo
says we're going to update our
configuration settings in our config.yml
file i'm going to make the title data
slice
i'll put my email in i'll add a
description put in the author
for the base url i'm going to leave this
empty this is the text that would show
up at the end of
your github website but because this is
the only github website linked on my
github account
i'm going to leave the base url empty
and i'm going to replace url with
dataslice yt dot github.io i'm going to
also remove
all the social profiles for now just
because i'm not using any and i'll go
ahead and save this file and then it
says step three is to build our site
so i'll go ahead and copy this command
bundle exec jekyll serve
and in vs code i can actually go to view
terminal and i'll paste my code and it
should start running a local server for
you
you might have an error that comes up
that says you don't have the
dependencies
and if that's the case you just need to
run bundle install
and then bundle exec check will serve
but once you get your site up and
running
you can go to your browser go to
localhost 4000 and you should see
what looks like the live preview we
looked at earlier but now with your own
title description
and other items that you configured in
your config file all the posts are still
here you can tell
from the posts folder we have the
corresponding files but i'll remove that
in a later video
so once we've done our main website
configuration we want to go ahead and
commit these changes back to our github
repo that way we can view
our website not just locally but also on
dataslice.github.io so we're going to
stop our server and really quickly
you'll actually notice this new folder
here in gray
called site and each time we run the
command to start our server jekyll is
actually taking
all of our content here and generating a
static site that our browser can
interpret and it puts it in this site
folder so that's actually what github is
doing too
through github pages it's generating a
static site so we actually don't need to
upload this folder back to github and
you'll notice in our git ignore file
which tells us what folders to ignore
you'll see that site
is in here but anyway to commit our
changes for the config.yml file we'll
click on our version control button in
vs code type in a commit message
so i'm going to just call this basic
site configuration and
we'll go ahead and stage and commit
these changes so now we've locally
committed our changes but now we need to
push it back to our github repo so we'll
go down here
to push one commit to origin master and
hit ok
and now it'll actually push these
changes back to our github repo
so if we go back to our repo and refresh
you can see that i made a commit 43
seconds ago called basic site
configuration
and if we go to datasliceyt.github.io
we see our live website here so that's
all for this video and in the next one
i'm going to cover how to add blog posts
both manually written
and directly from rstudio i know that
everyone may have varying levels of
experience so if any of this was
confusing to you
i just want to point you to a couple
more resources that i'll also link in
the description
if you want to learn more about jekyll
i'd recommend the giraffe academy
tutorial series most of what i learned
is actually straight from these videos
for html and css i'd recommend w3schools
and for more information on github pages
i'll share this link to the getting
started documentation and as always if
you have any other questions feel free
to leave a comment below and i'll try to
get back to you thanks for watching and
i'll catch you next one